Harvey could tell he was shooting in
town when he was shooting in town he'd
usually uh uh rent a house in Malibu so
he would invite friends to come over for
the weekend and and hang out and so I
come over to Harvey's there's Bruce
Willis I've never met him before oh he
had already read Pulp Fiction by the
time I show up at Harvey's house so
we're taking a nice walk along the beach
because so look I uh I write your script
I want to play Vincent kind of have uh
John Travolta set up for Vincent okay
well here's the deal then what if I play
Jewels because look I know he's black he
could just be a hipster dude but it's
not right but I think you should be in
this movie you you understand it there
is a third lead here that I think you
would be perfect for I would just ask
you to read the script one more time
with the idea of you playing Butch it
goes okay I'll do that I can do that and
then I call them the next day and he
said Quentin the shortest sentence in
the Bible is Jesus wept
the shortest sentence in Hollywood is
I'm in